when I first started I just want to make
$2,000 these people that's big aren't
actually perceived to be B they're not
being there just because they treat
themselves like they're be I was gonna
be a doctor okay you know be a lawyer or
was gonna be you know I didn't see
myself on the street I every day he's an
American rapper from Los Angeles since
2008 he has released five independent
mixtapes he is known for his laid-back
slow wordplay and unique storytelling
he's Dom Kennedy and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success rule
number three is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys like
the best and as always as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
in the comments below put quotes around
it to other people can be inspired as
well and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with you as
well enjoy
what I try to do is to always know
better myself I'm saying as a person as
just a human being or gods I report you
know what you want to call it I feel
like you know focusing on too much today
kids focus on and even a lot of my
friends the end result which is the
money you know the fame and all of that
side but it's like if you don't learn
anything about yourself if you don't
take anybody with you you don't say if
you don't change anybody's life for the
better you do it alone
and it's not gonna be messy nothing you
don't end up somewhere Bioscope unhappy
about it anyway you know that's kind of
like what I tell my friends and how I
try to live my life was there ever a
point that you were so close to quitting
yeah it was I wouldn't say oh I don't I
couldn't say like so close like I don't
know how close you know right but it was
definitely a time where I was just like
you know I dunno I didn't have me a lot
of expectations like I said I didn't you
know I just I got to a point where I had
I had done a lot of things I had kind of
passed like when I first started I just
want to make $2,000 that's all I'm gonna
tell my friends like man if I could make
to figure out a way to make $2,000 a
month you know I would be happy so y'all
not there wow yeah man it was $24
brothers coming back at a certain point
I did I put out music I I traveled and
it was just like yeah I was questioning
like what you know you got to find a
reason everyday to want to still do
something so have to kind of refocus but
yeah it was though man take you're so
serious you know don't wait on nobody
else to validate you take yourself
serious you know I'm saying cuz people
only Gomez with you as serious as you
take yourself so if you think you a
small time everybody gonna think you
small time you know I'm saying nobody
ain't gonna have no reason to people
that's big or hard actually proceed to
be big they're not being there just
because they treat themselves like there
be you comes to hand a they act they act
important they're important people to
themselves so the world has to take us
sets because you know that's who you are
most important lessons online was this
man don't be scared to take a chance you
know
ourselves like nothing is guaranteed
it's nothing that you ever gonna do or
you're gonna know exactly for sure that
the outcomes gonna be successful but you
got to go anyway you know you got to
protect yourself in the only way you
could do that is by working hard you
know to guarantee that the outcome will
be a one that you're like you know I'm
saying that's all and that's what it
takes a lot to get to that point where
it's like you know you're okay with
putting music out in and putting out
albums and stuff but I like to do it
until I feel like I'll get I've given
enough to that project and then when I'm
at that place and I'm satisfied and I
feel like no matter the outcome I'm
happy with it that's it that's when it
comes out I was reading an article on
you on Forbes which is amazing because
for you to be on Forbes do we really
studying your work of the independent
artists and kind of how you are in a
position where you can tell the label
this is what I want and then tell them
now I'm not going to take that deal
because I already got my movement no
Meah about how you got to that place
because obviously does it happen
overnight
no it happen gradually you know out of
necessity rhythm you know it started
with me now really just being a fan of
music first of all I say that like I was
in when I was a kid when I was younger
you know and I was you know in my early
twenties you feel me I wasn't really
never be a rapper I mean you know I'm
saying I always wrote out right off like
a lot of kids in inner-city crime or you
know I'm saying and a little brandy buy
albums but then I thought I start
putting out music and learning more you
know ecologist prepared me for this you
know so every project I did every
failure I had it make me smarter it made
me stronger you know every time when I
slid right after I was late I got up you
know said it and then we just kept going
and just kept building Hill avoid you
know fill avoid jobs out here figure out
what what you can make better that's
better than any job like you could go
get a job doing something whatever you
don't want to but figure out where you
could really fit in and be happy in
there worried about the money's income
that's not
be a problem because if you feeling a
void and you add into you know whatever
you might you might be like you know
what they don't have good food I've been
used I'm saying and you might just be
the person in the next billionaire to
just have bomb food at concerts like
straight up though straight up though
I'll just figure out a way to involve
like media in concerts like where people
could be there and you could like you
know whatever some type web but just
figure out something that people is not
doing you know I'm saying that you feel
like people could utilize and do that
what's your interest definition of
success um you know for me is just
people I permission filming I was the
last one on the yellow hour you know and
I was really the message you know that I
learned it all that time all my time
doing music up to that point for me that
was extension you know people happiness
year for me you know happiness was just
give to my all you know so whatever I'm
doing at the time again it's not you
know like a hymen song to project like I
was my biggest project today like every
way for free you know and so it wasn't
really you know obviously if I you know
proven to myself like I would do this
for free so I definitely would do it for
me obviously but it's not ready for that
you know it's for something else for me
you know and it was definitely at that
time and it was just to be dedicated to
something for your life to have a
purpose
I decided around 2005 that I wanted to
be you know
[Music]
okay and that was something I had
already been involved in you know just
as a childhood it was like it was a
passion of mine
so our figured it was my best you know
right to take applying everything I know
everything I had like I was gonna be a
doctor
okay to be a lawyer I was gonna be you
know I didn't see myself as on a silver
tie every day love just being honest or
you know kind of look down a list of
language so possibility you know what
are you going to do so you know it's
kind of like we chose each other I guess
I know any project with a yellow oppelo
step higher than what I normally do is
you know smoothly and I had it was very
ambitious project you know it was pounds
when I was making it that I was really
help you know with that the far far
above his heart is snow
Salinger's go you know I think that's
why he liked his project and you saw
were three or you know the logic is
already know that knowledge assistant a
long time now it will prefer the same
they know a license when switching off
or to happy
right I get inspired by life a lot and
that's my way of you know giving back
and expressing in people you know I get
acquired by people basically and that's
my way of you know I'm showing that is
music so the only way I could do that is
the way I do that is with Repsol so I
soon as I find a beat or music that I
love I can get to show me giving back so
it's like I sit around I go to studios I
away for those moment to hear music that
I love that I could write something I'll
never win before it and make a song that
I feel like the words never heard before
kids you know for my area and people
like they never learned before just
inspire them to do something different
be themselves even more you know like if
you listen to my music you know it
varies from sometime but i but it kind
of stays the sense the same in terms of
uniqueness like I would think so you
know like I just look for unique I wants
a professional adji you know I mean
sound like a real person that really
knows what they're doing maybe like I
don't I don't like to you know I don't
know it's different levels of you know
musicianship it but the people that I
tend to work with are more like you know
like how I am they're they're sore about
what like I'm sure when I write a song
or when I'm dying here when I hit the
stage like I know what I'm gonna do you
know so I look for producers I have that
same confidence and what they do you
know and it's not worried about trying
to do it everybody's trying to get and
just have their own day that they bring
to the table that's what I look for
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this hoodie because Mikey linen
asked me to also if you want to nominate
someone for the next top ten video
please check the description for a link
to a video where you can vote for people
and put in your suggestions as well I'd
love to know what did you take from this
video what was the most important lesson
that you learned that blew your mind
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow
please leave it down the comments below
I'm super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to Clyde
Hays Clyde thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word
taking that picture posting the
Instagram I love the effects you put on
it I really appreciate the support and I
hope you're enjoying the book so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
I can't tell no me or no kid nobody that
you should try your best in school if
I'm not trying my best at what I'm doing
and I'm saying they gonna know they like
man you you just getting over like you
late I want to just be like you but it's
like no I'm not getting over it I don't
go to sleep
you're something like I'll be up
stretching nights working trying to
figure out perfect way so you know
express myself in you know come up with
t-shirt designs like this is this is
something I do because I love you you
know I'm saying and I loved and I work
hard at it and it rewards me for being
loyal to it you know not the other way
around like y'all just get pages because
you show up so I know after you release
the other album you sort of toured the
world and all that sort of for the first
time how did those kind of experiences
affect you and exactly Oh first of all
it showed me just really the power
answers you know believing in yourself
you know could be making a yellow album
you know it was it wasn't a risk at all
the calculated risk if anything but it
just showed the power of me to me of
believing in yourself in believe me of a
art